shutting up shop in the South of France
as world leaders and protesters arrived
for the g7 summit security is tight
around the small seaside town of
Barrett's France is deploying thirteen
thousand police officers alongside
soldiers and drones to protect the site
for Boris Johnson it's the culmination
of a week of pressing the flesh on the
continent pushing the case for a new
brexit deal it's the new Prime
Minister's first big international event
and speaking about brexit ahead of it he
said some people questioned the
Democratic decision this country has
made fearing that we will retreat from
the world
some think Britain's best days are
behind us to those people I say you are
gravely mistaken
while Downing Street has played down any
chances of an immediate brexit
breakthrough this weekend will give
Boris Johnson vital FaceTime with EU
leaders and the European Council
President Donald Tusk but with
representatives from across the world
descending on the small French town
other issues such as the environment are
likely to dominate protesters have
already targeted a chemicals factory
near to the summit French President
Emmanuel macron has put the Environment
squarely on the agenda with Boris
Johnson also saying he will urge action
to tackle climate change back in the UK
the Labour leader says the message must
get through to everybody the
environmental emergency the whole world
faces is serious global warming that's
going on global pollutions going on and
the fires in the Amazon rainforest which
President Wilson are of Brazil is
actually promoting so put all the press
you can on President Trump to recognize
just how dangerous the situation is
around the world leaving Washington
overnight Donald Trump could also be
flying into arguments over his hardline
stance on Iran along with his views on
Russia and policies on China before he
left the president spoke to Boris
Johnson by phone when they sit down
tomorrow the Prime Minister will say the
NHS will not be on the table in any
future post brexit deal betrayed won't
be the only topic of conversation it
will be a difficult balancing act on
something like relations with Iran for
instance America is out of step with all
its European allies and I think on this
too
Boris Johnson will want to side with the
Europeans on trade matters of course
it's very important that an an early
trade deal is struck whether it's the
protesters outside or the politicians in
a relaxing weekend by the seaside this
won't be Rob Paul Sky News